I think it would have found really
important I think you would have found
that hold on a second we're speaking of
don't interrupt the lady I think it
would have found that it was completely
discredited my point your mansplaining
here sir it's time for installment two
of build the wall changed my mind at
least it was until wobbly were filming a
SafeZone materialized with protesters
and they lob some accusations which were
about what you'd expect
I don't engage with racist I don't
I'm gonna be right back I just would
like to go and have a word with the
protesters and see what issue it is hi
how are you hi I understand there's a
protest going on here from what what
we're doing today okay that's totally
fine and I know that none of you wanted
to come over and sit down and talk with
us about it yeah but why is that weird
that for one there's a fear of our
safety we don't want to be put online
with people that have similar beliefs to
you potentially with DOCSIS that come in
we feel that our point of view of us of
standing here was enough to be said but
now you've all come here and essentially
we're not always just at an interview
okay
I didn't mean to forced you into an
interview I mean you are in a public
space where you have a permit to be here
and we set up and it's been very civil
there hasn't been anyone threatening to
Docs anybody and I would obviously
discourage anyone from daxing anyone at
any point but I would actually love the
whole reason we're here is that we can
have discussions with people like
yourselves people who disagree with us
and so I don't want to misrepresent my
points that's fair that's her you don't
have to but I do find it just curious
that you guys set up in response to what
we're doing but no one wants to have a
dialogue isn't the whole point right now
to be having more dialogue okay but not
with the people whom you're protesting
no the students who a lot of students
are over there well yeah I'm great and I
would direct them over to come and sit
down
so that we can talk with him as well I
mean that's all purpose to this I would
I would love if any of you would be
willing to come and sit down have a
conversation it's not gotcha we're not
looking to hurt anybody I would never
ever want anyone to harm any of you but
I do think this is part of the divide
that we have here in United States right
now where people show up we invite
everyone to sit down and have a
conversation and then those I would
imagine more on the left yourself simply
refused to have a dialogue I don't think
that's productive
sure yeah you want to come and grab grab
a talk show chat right what we invited
you over so I came over here and you
just said I forced the interview okay
okay that's that's a problem with the
dialogue I was telling Hillary over
there yeah using certain tactics like
okay I understand there's a large crowd
over there that we could control the
narrative not control the narrative more
push it in the wrong way no big news or
anything but I you're surrounded by a
whole crowd of people it's easy for
people to misconstrue you say but
talking points in your mouth I don't
want to do that do you feel like I've
done that that I put talking about you
specifically but you know we've been
talking to people all day and sometimes
people jump in with things they think
will say because they don't understand
our point of view but I'm only inviting
you to speak with me I don't think I've
done that that's fine immigrants are
welcome here change my mind all right
well would you be welcome for me to
change your mind okay but I don't
understand the whole purpose to it you
know the segment that we've started is
to change my mind it's to invite
dialogue you're kind of missing the
whole point to it if you're saying
change my mind and I'm saying well let
me try to change your mind and you say I
don't want to talk you probably
shouldn't be okay yeah I think some
people we have we holder believes sure
but a lot of people aren't comfortable
in the crowd situation they don't need
to be
I am very uncomfortable in a crowded
situation by the way we didn't advertise
we didn't advertise this this happened
because we showed up and just had a sign
so this is it wasn't something like a
live speaking event was it put on
Twitter was he okay
so whatever you think yeah I know I've
heard it a couple of roaming to that
Crowder here's a racist I don't say that
did you only did you say that steam
crackers or that you believe I'm a
racist I
engage races okay don't feel comfortable
engaging with you right now is that
because you think I'm a racist
it's because you're crowding me and
you've brought a crowd of people in
multiple cameras so I really don't
appreciate how you're crowding me like
I'm not crowding you right now and
giving you some space
well we're in the public space and you
have a sign that says changed my mind I
see you didn't know I appreciate hey
that's Bo there you go I appreciate it
come on you're in good spirits I
appreciate you being so so friendly but
I do think to lob the accusation of
racism that's a pretty pretty healthy
accusation I prefer engaging in smaller
crowds and I don't appreciate how
everyone's here staring at me and how
you've brought these people - you did
protest my event and used our segment
changed my mind
I mean it's sound like it's all that
surprising that I'm asking you about
your opinions you're asking someone to
change your mind and you said that you
wouldn't engage with racists and you
wouldn't engage with me I think that's
fair No
I don't think you're hearing I am
hearing you I've asked you to leave me
alone and you're not doing that so I
don't think you're hearing you know you
don't have to speak I'm just simply
asking you said you want to engage with
me you wanna engage with racists so you
haven't told anyone or insinuate that
I'm a racist and you don't believe that
I'm a racist okay well let me tell you
I'm not a racist and I don't think that
our opinion here build a wall change my
mind is racist at all
I do think to say that you're not going
to engage with racists implies that
everyone who disagrees with you as a
racist and I think that's a tactic to
shut down dialog which is what you're
doing right now I think more
conversation is better but that's okay I
won't i won't bother if you don't want
to talk I don't think the sign is very
well advised if you don't want to talk
with people tonight yes so I think that
if they don't want to speak that's fine
but I don't think it's something that
you should try and hang over their head
if they've told you already that
something that makes them uncomfortable
I don't think that you should try and
prop them up as this figurehead for all
of us right now which is what you were
trying to do I think it's a little
underhanded but I'm more than happy to
speak to you because I don't like
calling someone a racist might be
underhanded well yeah but that's not the
point I'm trying to make right now so
the point I was making okay I don't know
what they said to you I don't know what
was said before I got here I just got
here five minutes ago so I'm not gonna
speak on that but I'm gonna speak to the
fact that you are coming on to our
campus you're asking us to engage with
you with what is a very hot button issue
you know that it's going to provoke an
emotional response from all of us you
know that this is a campus full of
international students bully multi rape
I can you hold it for a second no I
agree with you I don't getting yeah I'm
not I don't want people to shout out No
and so you come on to our campus you
know that this is a very international
campus we're all very multicultural we
all are very inclusive so I think for
you to come into our campus with such an
inflammatory question that's based on a
policy made by somebody who is called
second rapists that a policy coming from
racist beliefs you know I think that
it's pretty I think it's pretty cruel to
come on to our campus knowing our
background and to demand our free labor
our emotional labor to try and engage
with you may and that yes you man may I
speak well let me finish I'm almost done
okay
and I think it's pretty cruel to try and
exploit us for our emotional labor
because you know that it's gonna get an
issue from that or a response from us
you know that a huge crowd like this is
gonna form and I just think that it's
really shady of you to come on to our
campus for that you've already you're
repeating yourself now so can I speak go
or do what do you want to write is there
something else that you would need to
say that pretty much it
okay so everything you've just said is
inaccurate why is it accurate well first
up it's not a policy that Donald Trump
created he didn't call all Mexicans
rapists and by the way we have a permit
to be here and we're not exploiting
anyone's labor people are free to sit
down whether they choose to discuss the
topic or not by the way there's nothing
offensive about the idea of building the
wall half of America supports the idea
everything that you just said is
factually verifiably inaccurate and
that's okay that I understand you have
an emotional reaction and I'm not trying
to upset you but I do think that the
truth here matters as well and if people
are going to paint all of their
opposition as racist as these people
have done here I think that does a great
disservice to dialog here in the United
States we're trying to engage in
dialogue so I've been here with the
little group of protesters all day and
like everyone there was only one person
who said that you were racist okay and
so I don't I think it's a
mischaracterization because I want to
commit debating okay can you tell me who
it was
I'm not calling on people okay you know
people what kind of like calling someone
out as a racist I don't know I know
because um I mean these people online it
will demonize them and I'm not trying to
get them in trouble
you know the people I understand and by
the way I think you'll be pleasantly
surprised by the response online because
of how respectful and how civil you've
been regardless of where we disagree I
really do appreciate that yeah and the
whole I think that if you would have
instead of sitting here and I know you
didn't but mingling with people who've
accused me of racism or as you say
trying to exploit free emotional labor
whatever that means
I think he would have found really
important I think he would have found
that hold on a second we're speaking
here don't interrupt the lady I think it
would have found that was completely
discredited my point your mansplaining
here sir I think you would have can you
let me speak with her
you spoke for a much longer period of
time than her I'm answering their speed
to defend my tonight can i address what
she just said I think that if you would
have sit down and had a conversation you
would have found that it's very similar
to what we're doing right now right it
really it's designed to evoke what's
happening right now it's not designed to
insulting anybody I want people like you
on this campus I disagree with your
points of view yeah but I appreciate
that you're respectful I appreciate that
you're willing to talk I hope you
understand that's the point to this and
I hope you don't feel like I've been an
aggressor toward your any point I think
we're creating a dialogue and it's not
inflammatory there's not any punch in
your fighting anymore you like that's
true but I think the only reason why
I've stayed over here mostly is that
because we have we have a most like okay
we have a big immigrant population here
is that people who deal day-to-day with
like yeah I think you know then you'll
understand because we have a lot of
birch to immigrants who are dealing with
their visa and the stress of like of
immigration every day that I stayed over
here because there's people we need to
have I think it shows that even with the
crowd even there all I people who
descended to you in the crowd that
having a dissent over here showed that
they weren't alone because I know I
could be scary for some people sure I
understand and believe me one thing I
used to tell the stories to do stand-up
comedy I used to get so violently ill
because I I really do have a fear of
public speaking and I think a lot of
people do I think even more so when
there's a culture of fear as you see on
college campus where people are afraid
of speaking out because they're
admonished as a racist right is you
didn't but yeah we've heard some people
say it and that's the whole reason for
this is there are a lot of students
there who have actually been other do
maybe agree with the point or maybe
don't but they want to see people have a
dialogue so I do I have no problem with
you being here protesting
the only issue I have is what will
people lob accusations and throw throw
accusations from afar can we can we have
a handshake or
hand-shaker broke bro how'd you do bro
gender neutral bro huh gulps I
appreciate it and you're welcome to come
and grab a seat thank you very much you
if you want to come over grab a seat
you're more than welcome
I just want to explain what emotional
labor is because more than you're more
than welcome to do it over there and
we're sitting we have a permit we have a
permit there so I'm wanting to take this
opportunity to show these people just
what changed my mind was all about we
decided to sit down with Nicolas and see
if we could smooth things over
that's good that's fine what was your
name sir Nicolas Nicolas now do you see
how sitting down here outside of the
rain this breeds more friendly
productive conversation I don't want to
shout out there I think it's nice to be
out of the rain
good would you like your granola bar I'm
good thing okay all right so Nicolas you
said you would like I know we're kind of
off the path to build the wall changed
my mind but you were seemed pretty upset
I would say that you were shouting but I
guess you don't see it that way and
that's okay by the way I don't begrudge
you what is it that you wanted to
clarify for me well I think that when
you were speaking to the other protestor
you tried well you didn't try you
outwardly said and dismiss my notion
that you're exploiting utd students
emotional labor and I want to explain to
you what that was so that you might have
a better idea of what at least in my
view I'm aware of what it is I disagree
with your statement why do you disagree
with my statement I'm not abusing
anyone's emotional labor here because
I'm not forcing anyone to sit down no
one is required to okay people are here
of their own volition and by the way
everyone has had a productive
conversation Nicolas like except for you
you're the only one to have yelled today
I if I yelled I'm sorry but that's okay
I appreciate it okay I didn't intend on
yelling but I felt like I took offense
to my notion being outright dismissed
and I just dismiss it I just disagree
with it okay and I will rebut it and say
that when you come onto a college campus
especially one where we've explained
multiple times the college campus that
you TV is with a statement like build
the wall change my mind I think you know
that you're gonna get a lot of
we'll response from that and even if
it's from people's free will then it's
still something that you're coming on to
the campus to kind of break up the flow
of everyday life to try and get a
response for and you're gonna take that
monetize it and try and show yourself in
the best light because of it and I don't
think that it's very right and you can
do that all you want I'm not saying that
you can't do that but it does raise a
bit of a red flag with me concerning the
utd administration for letting this
happen and I think that if you don't
like this we should all go to the utd
administration and tell them what we
think of it because I think that it's a
little ridiculous to have somebody who
wants it inflame us but do you really
love it I appreciate you guys guys hold
on I appreciate it but I don't really
want to go to the power of the mob I
like Nikolas and I to have a
conversation if that's wondering if you
want to govern this whole thing by a
poll I don't think you're gonna like how
it turns out and so I don't want to do
that I think it's important to let your
arguments I think it's a word of like
your statements rest on the laurels of
substantiation of your arguments here a
couple of things first off we we do have
a permit obviously and if you don't like
it that's fine it's it's very typical of
people who disagree with us to try and
simply shut us down rather than engage
in dialogue and I'm not trying to shut
you down I'm trying what would you call
going to the administration making sure
that we can't do it again
I'm saying tell them what we think of it
I'm not saying okay sure it doesn't
happen again okay but I think that and
what do you think of it think of what
well what would you tell them what do
you think of this why would you walk if
you would walk into their office and say
steven crowder and change my mind is i
think it's disrespectful to people who
are immigrants who have closed
immigrants or or close friends who are
immigrants family who have emigrated I
think that especially Latin ex
immigrants if you were trying to have a
discussion about a very sensitive issue
for those people outright saying build
the wall change my mind as a subhead is
going to inflame them it's going to call
to mind the
strong emotions of what it means for
those people to come across the border
here Nicholas let me let me ask you
something yes do you ever notice you
you're very concerned about this
inflaming people yes do you ever notice
that you're primarily the one who's
inflamed I think that I'm one of the few
people who's speaking for the inflamed I
think as you pointed out earlier most of
the people here on your side know
everyone disagrees
every single person okay but there are
people who are saying that they love it
that's like a sport
how do people love it who don't even
agree with me they just like that we're
having a conversation let me ask you
this okay do you discuss immigration
issues here on a college campus we do
you do would you say you even do it in
class yes okay so what is the issue with
discussing it from a different point of
view I think when the point of view
comes from a point of exclusion from a
point that paints it against people who
are most likely to be affected by a
policy like building the wall I think
that it needs to be done in a more
sensitive way and that's my issue with
it is we're coming at it from it sounds
to me like your issue is someone
discussing the issue if they disagree
with you no it's not I think that if
it's coming if the disagreement is
coming from a place of prejudice I think
that that's an issue I believe that I
believe that we should build the wall we
should secure our borders and deploy the
illegal immigrants and make sure that we
don't have any more illegal immigrants
but the countries are already happening
there's already a four the point is is
that border well that's what we're
talking about is that offensive at all
is that marginalizing at all I think
that when you're talking about divesting
money from things like public education
like health care like shutting down the
entire government because of the wall
and disenfranchising government workers
who can't afford to live anymore I think
that when you're centering the topic of
immigration around that issue it becomes
very polarizing and very low so let me
ask you this yes what would be the
acceptable way for someone who disagrees
with you on immigration to express it I
think that
they could easily talk about the fact
that the immigration numbers are already
decreasing I think that there's someone
who would agree with you I'm asking if
someone disagrees with you and believes
in strong national border security
someone believes in cracking down on
work visas someone who disagrees with
you what would be the acceptable way but
for them to express it according to you
Nicholas well I think that we're at a
point where we disagree on the state of
border security because I think it's
already very strong there's already a
border fence there's already strong
funding for the border patrol for ice
and I don't necessarily think those are
good things but I think that that's the
facts of it
so I would say that I don't disagree
that there isn't strong border security
I'm saying that's not disagreeing I i am
disagreeing by saying there isn't yeah
so you keep I keep asking you what is
the accepted way for someone who
disagrees with you and you keep going
through arguments that agree that that
agree with your position
well I pointed someone like myself who
says security at the border is bad we
have seven eight hundred miles of
completely unprotected border okay a
little immigration is a serious problem
a hundred and sixteen billion dollars
footed to the American taxpayer every
year okay what to you would be the
acceptable way for someone who disagrees
with you to express himself or herself
or Z so I think that you could explain
that you could those are acceptable ways
to disagree with that you are receptive
because you're respectfully stating
facts you are going about things without
trying to paint it about race like what
the current president has done on the
campaign trail I haven't I know you
haven't I'm not saying that it's you
who's doing that I'm saying that it's
supporting a policy created out of that
created from somebody who has those
beliefs and I think that when people
want to disagree about the state of
border security and they want to say
that it's weak I think that as long as
they're not going back to saying that
they don't want people of a certain race
to come into the United States sure I
think wouldn't go and I don't
has nothing to do with race at all it
has to do with national border security
so I don't I haven't said that when we
agreed yeah okay good I think that I
think that's a little implicit but I
don't know hold on it's not I would like
to okay just one thing I think see how
the energy is coming down here I think
we're having a pretty good conversation
okay I would think that this is a little
more productive than when we started off
would you agree I would agree but I also
came into the fray when you were shoving
a camera in my friends face who was very
clearly uncomfortable right it was a
person who called me a racist and so the
whole purpose to this to sitting down
okay to having this conversation so we
can talk the way we just did I know what
you just described right what you I just
said hey what would be the acceptable
way to express an opinion with which you
would disagree okay you just described
exactly what we've done here all day
okay so it seems like your mind has
changed my mind on what has changed your
mind at least on the idea that we can be
here and do what we do without it being
designed to be inflammatory or as you
said was it abusing students emotional
labor exploiting this is I don't I don't
think this constitutes I will disagree
with that still but I think that I've
said all I need to say on the matter
today okay but will we agree that this
is probably a little bit better than you
thought it was going to be that it
hasn't been bickering and soundbites I
haven't I haven't inserted any words
into your mouth hasn't been hateful will
we agree on that I agree that I've
presented myself in the way that I see
most of it okay that's all I can say you
see that that this whole segment is
about rationalizing one's own position
can soothe even the most savage beast
not everyone I do not think that there
should be any order in that sense you
don't I do not okay so you don't believe
in countries I like I said I believe in
the line if you really draw a line
between Amer
in Mexico that's fine that's on a map
but I'm saying if there's nothing but
just a field of grass there I think
that's possible yeah well you can't win
em all
stay tuned tomorrow for the full
installment of build the wall changed my
mind volume 2